building a dynamic link library for C++
today and I'm going to walk you through
every step of that we're gonna be using
Visual Studio 2019 so if you don't
already have Visual Studio 2019
community edition you might want to go
grab that first you can find it on the
internet it is free make sure you get
development with C++ checked when you
install that and now to make a dynamic
link library so let's go ahead and open
this Visual Studio and we're gonna do
create a new project and here we're
gonna get some a bunch of default
projects we're gonna type in dynamic up
here just to do a search and we're
looking for a dynamic link library DLL
make sure this is set to C++ windows and
all project types okay so we're just
gonna go ahead and double click on that
and we need to give this project a name
now I am gonna go mainly off the default
documentation on creating these dll's
so if you want to follow along on a
guide you can just google how to create
a dynamic link library with c++ and you
will find a walkthrough from Microsoft
that is pretty good so I'm gonna base a
lot of what I'm doing here basically off
of that same document but I'm gonna add
my own little thing to it what basically
some improvements well what I would
consider improvements okay so we're
gonna call this math library helps the
spell library correctly just because
that is a very well we're not actually
gonna call it we're gonna call it we're
gonna call it fit library you'll see why
it's basically because the default
function we're going to put in here is
Fibonacci sequence err so it's not a
math library it's more of just for
Fibonacci only and what we're going to
do here we're going to add
a new item and a header item we're going
to call this header I will just call it
fit library so same name as this project
and there it is and I'm gonna do a
copy/paste from Microsoft's website here
is the website so I'm basically just
copying in this but we will walk through
it don't worry just so you know where
this is if you want to find it and
there's not gonna be a github repo or
anything like that for this particular
project okay so as we go through this we
see that it has some defines at the top
and that way we get the import or export
declared and you'll see in this header
it has some extern just header functions
for fibonacci and knit next current and
index okay so our next step here is to
basically build or add the object for
this so we do the same thing add new
item this time we're going to do a C++
file and this one is it's going to be
the same name and there we go so once
again I'm going to copy from that site
and just paste in here however we do
need to change a few things this is now
fib library not math library and we
could change these math library exports
and all these names which I think I will
yeah we're gonna change these all to fit
library rather than math library and I
did that in case you weren't sure by
double-clicking it and pressing and
holding down control and pressing o Orr
and that's where you get this option to
rename like so and it renames everything
across your project that is using this
so it's super nice it doesn't want to
seem to want to do it here maybe it's
coming because there's nothing using it
yeah we got to be careful about these
names if we mess any of them up will
surely get some errors so just taking a
quick look here looks like everything
else is fine okay very good
all right if we go ahead and build this
with control B or you can go up to build
do it up there too you'll see that it
succeeds so one succeeded I was actually
expecting errors or died hours but
warnings so I'm surprised that I got no
warnings but that's fine so now we have
this all built but nothing is using it
yet so let's make a project to do it we
could either do a whole new solution or
we could do it within the same project
in both ways are fine so let's see let
me go ahead and I'll show you just doing
a completely separate project so we're
going to exit out of this actually we're
doing new and we want to do new solution
really doesn't have that option I don't
think it does so maybe we do have to
exit out of this go ahead and go to exit
and just relaunch Visual Studio
and will once again create a new project
this time we're just going to do a
console app just the standard console
and we'll call this I call this fib
client and it does have to be in the
same location and you'll see why in a
minute here we basically have to make
the path and go to that other project so
we're gonna need to set up the includes
so we go over here to our little project
right click on it and go to properties
you can also to click this gear or
there's someone somewhere else you can
do too I think under project properties
yeah or you can press the hotkey alt f7
many ways to get here anyway we want to
include the header from the other file
and to do that we'll go to C++ general
and under additional include directories
we are gonna path to the other library
so we'll click this new new line then
we'll hit well we could go to it like
like so in length manually path to it
where is it fit library there it is then
fit the library again and then ok and
that will get us to where the headers
are but also what we can do is we can
just back up a couple directories like
so and as long as this the other project
is in the same folder it should work and
just hit OK on that and now we want to
update this code I'm gonna use some code
for further down on that walkthrough
just bring it over for a second and it's
just the the code that uses the actually
actual Fibonacci library so I'm going to
copy on there and just paste it into
here we gotta change a few things of
course this is fib library
and it finds it right away since we have
it already included and now the next
thing we need to do is get the DLL
linked up in the library linked up so to
do that well once again go back into
properties and this time we're going to
go into linker and then into input and
we just want to bring in the name of
that library it was FID library and it
just on live because it's always dot
live here actually I think there are
some cases where it can be a dot obj but
in our case it's going to be food
library dot line
oh yes and let me go back in there
because we need one other thing and that
is the additional library directories
and that's under linker general not
seeing it but it's in here somewhere
additional library directories there it
is so we'll go ahead and edit that and
we'll add in a similar path this is a
little tricky because you could be
building and release or you could be
building and debug and it's going to go
to a different folder either way so we
can macro this and rather than saying
release or debug here and have to
manually change that anytime we switch
our projects building we can just put in
a macro or int dur I think that means
intended directory not one percent on
that but it's a at the Ender macro so if
we hit OK on that and apply we should
now be able to find that fib library
don't lie because we have these
additional library directories
so let's go ahead and run this it should
get an error but we just want to confirm
well all it build first I'll do it this
way so you can explicitly see what I'm
doing and it does build successfully but
when we try to run this console app we
get an error and says the code execution
cannot proceed because fib library DLL
was not found reinstalling the program
me may fix this problem well in our case
it's not but the fib library DLL was not
found we found the normal dot live but
we didn't find the DLL so what we need
to do is we need to copy the DLL into
this directory so if I go to open file
and File Explorer basically needs to be
I think just right in here and then it
will run however we don't want to have
to manually copy it over we don't have
to go to fib library and here wherever
the DLL is I think it's actually in here
there it is we don't want to have to
give a copy and back to the other one
and then into here and then paste every
time we update it so rather than do that
hold this macro and a post build on our
client here and in this post build we'll
copy it in if it needs to only if it's
been updated or if it's not there so
well once again go back into the
properties and scroll down on this
configuration properties on the side to
build events and then command line in
the command line it's the same thing
they have over here it is an ex copy
with /y and slash D of this directory to
the outer of your project and as you can
see the previous directory once again
depends on that same resolution so we're
gonna have to modify it a little bit in
our case to be fib library
and fib library so that all that should
path to the proper debug or release and
and to do the X copy as specified after
a build oops I do have this in the wrong
spot and when I cut this out of here it
needs to be in the post build so their
post build good catch okay so now we hit
okay and we'll see if we can resolve
this so now let's just go ahead and hit
play should do built in their ghosts so
now it just flew through the Fibonacci
sequence with our default code and there
we go we are now using a DLL we created
a DLL and used it set up everything we
needed to and let's see if we go into
this File Explorer we should see that
DLL wherever it needs to be I think it's
gonna be in here yeah it's under a debug
there's the fib library DLL copied in
there as it was supposed to so there you
go that's how you do it that's how you
generally make it DLL of course is a lot
more to it of course you can play around
now at this point first thing I did was
let the user input the Fibonacci
sequence and in turn you'd put a and B
here now when we run it we are prompted
we'll put in 534 and there it goes
runs through it starting at those using
our nice little fib library pretty cool
stuff right guys alright well thanks for
watching follow for more coding stuff
more videos about tech in tutorials and
whatnot and hopefully I'll see you guys
in the next video Oh actually meant to
have my webcam on apparently it's off
but oh well I know webcam video peace
out guys
the next one stay safe